[Music]
[Applause]
we didn't even mean to do that it's just
cause i said hey
it's tasty it's a very uh popular um
dish in new zealand which is strange
because i think it came all the way from
russia yeah via scandinavia to
uh new zealand but anyway we're back
this week guys we have our second part
of our fantastic interview with the
lovely samurai eagle from the legend of
vox magnum yes and critical room
indeed fantastic sam as we call them but
before we jump into that yeah let's uh
well first of all we need to tell you
guys of course you can always get hold
of um
our merchandise at the
friendshiponionpodcast.com there's some
fantastic things there to buy i
particularly like the hoodie i like the
hoodie too and i did make a promise and
it's yet to happen if i see someone in
the street come over to me yeah with
any friendship onion merch on them i
will take a picture of them and put it
on my social media account that could
get tricky when we start going to these
conventions because i'm assuming people
will be wearing some friendship onion
merch there and we're also hoping to do
some
live conventions from the pod from the
convention which we're working on right
i'm glad you said that tom because i was
just about to say if i see anybody in
merch i will give them ten dollars cash
but i won't do that because i just yeah
but yeah take a picture with him would
anyone like to see the friendship onion
live i don't know i would let us know
yeah send us an email at the friendship
on unitcastmedia.com
peeling the onion
housekeeping
how much fun are you
doing
[Music]
on you go bills right well see becky
wilson i see you becky wilson says it
always makes me happy when non-new york
folk tried to pronounce some of the
tones
she actually told us and becky wilson
has told us how to say it and i still
can't see it
you have to be careful with that
scan yeah
[Music]
there you go we've done it i think
you'll agree becky wilson we nailed
those thank you thank you becky we've
had some wonderful comments on our
youtube channel you can obviously you
don't need to just listen to us you can
watch us as well and great white shark
asaurus
said on our youtube uh channel i just
found this uh podcast through critical
role what's funny about that is that the
lord of the rings formed my love for
fantasy it has come full circle crazy it
is crazy nexaranda on youtube says this
was chemically constructed in a
laboratory for my exact interest well i
tell you what next surrender you've got
another you've got another half of it
right now when we start talking to sam
it's a strange uh one for me because my
best friend of all time apart from you
bills obviously yeah obviously
it's called tom murray and we have a
thomas murray i i would assume not my
thomas murray wrote in and said came
here for sam regal stayed for the lovely
banter of the legends that is billy and
dom subscribe he says not me although we
agree to subscribe it's very important
uh
well should we bring in sam because i
think it's about that time we spoke to
him for so long
about a subject that we're all very
interested in and again i need to
reiterate this because it's so important
for the podcast
if you're passionate about something if
you love talking about a particular
subject
get in touch with us because we love
talking to people who are passionate
about things
you're passionate about
i'm just looking at the size of your
water bottle it's a whopper isn't it
that looks like a scale double thing for
anyone just listening
the whopper that i was talking about was
my um
water bottle yeah it's a gallon a day so
i've been drinking a gallon a day for
the last three or four days
and
my god my toilet's seen some action is
that a gallon there this is a gallon
i've always wondered how much a gallon
is well it's a gallon a gallon is 128
fluid ounces or 3
800 milliliters
and uh they say that when you start
drinking a gallon like this it takes
about a week for your body to get used
to it so for the first week or so there
will be a significant amount of
urination and then your body will get
used to it i feel hydrated i feel
slightly confused i feel lonely and
scared when i go to the toilet so much
i'm scared no wonder but you look much
sexier
20 to 28 percent sexier on the eyes and
eyebrows oh thanks i'm going to say
something here and again if you're only
listening don't be concerned but would
you mind if i suck it no go ahead here
we go it's got a big straw in it
i've noticed that from 11 till uh one
and from one till three if i suck it 14
times i get there that was only four
then ten more to go go talk amongst
yourselves go
that is a lot of water
i mean i've got i've got a little dog
and i reckon he could swim in there
come on sam
it's great that that community can be so
healthy and strong and supportive not
only you know for what you guys were
doing but then when you guys come up
with a different idea to extend the show
they're like well here let's let's help
you make it yeah that's brilliant yeah
they're the best oh yeah brilliant
i also played a character in this recent
call of duty game with laura bailey hey
that's my friend yeah uh who has a
fantastic voice in his and is a
brilliant actor and
she was telling me all about the the
story of of critical role and i think it
was around about that time
that you guys got in contact with me and
we're like hey we have this character it
could be yeah yeah she might have
pitched you i i i can't remember how how
it first came up but uh you're fantastic
in the show by the way
uh everyone i i think i mean i don't
know when this episode of your podcast
airs but i while while we are recording
this we are mere hours away from your
character uh making his first appearance
yeah there's been a couple of minor
little teasers that i've seen online
which is really cool and also the great
thing
is so many people have gotten touched me
and said is that really you is that
really your voice because obviously i'm
doing a kind of
gruff
scotsman voice very different from the
way that i normally speak archibald
destiny who was slightly redesigned
totally redesigned he was an old man in
the original campaign
and we were like
who wants to see an old man run around
with the sword let's make him young and
vital and
swashbuckly and awesome and so i just
saw a clip of it this morning oh yeah
brilliant yeah your scottish accent is
fantastic it's very
very natural i've i thought if he's
lived a life of being a warrior and he's
got a couple of kind of nicks and cuts
on him and his hair's long and he has no
vanity and all this kind of stuff i'm
going to make his voice as grounded as i
can make it because in that group
you've obviously got so many different
dynamic characters and it seems like
archibald sometimes
can can express a little bit of
frustration of like hey guys let's
concentrate we're in real trouble here
you know we need to like fight to stay
alive i get that there's some quips
coming in and there's some dynamics that
are messed around but let's concentrate
so i thought i don't want to make him
entirely serious but i want his voice to
be a little bit more the voice of kind
of combat reason totally come on listen
yeah yeah yeah he's not a sourpuss and
he's not too serious but he is to the
point he's like all right all right
enough around let's go yeah yeah there's
some great moments when i was when i was
putting down the voice with you guys
where you guys had said
what would a scotsman say here and
obviously i've been friends with billy
for so long that i i was thinking what
would billy say in that situation you
allowed me to to call someone a dauber
obviously we did i don't know
i still don't know what that is but it's
in the show
if you need um
to know any scottish phrases my wife has
a company called gallus life look at
this i'm wearing it i'm wearing oh
billy's wife's t-shirt today okay can i
clap your dog
can i clap your dog yes which basically
means can i pet your dog oh and it's a
nice thing to say to someone if you meet
someone with a dog don't just go ahead
and clap it you've got to ask can i
consent yeah one of my favorite t-shirts
because nowadays t-shirts i find
t-shirts very hard to fit they tend to
be baggy here at the arm or too long
this t-shirt fits me like a dream your
wife's website to find stuff is gallis
life if you've ever gone to gallis life
it will tell you all that it might not
have dauber on there probably not oh she
should do a dog do a dobber shirt
yeah
brilliant but there's a lot of scottish
phrases up there you'll enjoy it you
should have a look
i will definitely i'll get some of her
merch and i'll bring you some of our
shirts can we talk about your shirt for
a second it's just me it's me on a shirt
what what could be more egotistical
i just saw you i was like oh did you
bring us one no no no you did not have a
guy they cost too much i'm not
of course of course i'll get you some i
need your sizes and stuff yeah let's do
that i also i i've never met you in
person even though you were on the show
we it was pandemic times this is the
first time i've ever laid eyes on you in
person we were always over zoom i don't
know if you're six foot eight i don't
know if you're five foot two i don't
know nothing he's very beautiful isn't
it he's a gorgeous face to face yeah i'm
petite i always wear my t-shirt small
like a little smaller than they should
be i like things tight tight oh so i'm
all i'm very small but that's another
thing to touch upon uh sam is
the pandemic yeah
actually kind of
forced certainly for me
uh
much more voice acting than i expected
to be doing i've obviously done peppered
a little bit of voice acting throughout
my career but during
you know kind of the the more serious
isolated times of
uh the pandemic when you guys reached
out to me it was made very clear listen
you're going to go into a studio
there'll be no one in that studio with
you everything will be sanitized
there'll be a technician who will never
come into the studio with you you'll
have a covet test when you show up
you'll you'll be expected to do you know
be cleaning your hands not touch certain
things leave your phone in a second
yeah it was all very safe
but it all i also remember leaving those
sessions thinking
is this the future you know for the next
couple of years or so is this really the
only thing as actors that will be doing
will be going into these sanitized areas
because it was the same with with call
of duty no one was allowed to take their
their face masks off until the last
minute none of the technicians could
take their face mass off throughout the
course of the entire day it was only
when you're acting that you could do it
and i remember thinking
is this is this where we've got to now
you know you know yeah crazy i mean it's
slightly resetting back maybe yeah but
you don't know how i mean we don't know
like i also uh direct a lot of voice
over uh in my career
and i haven't been to a studio since the
pandemic started because now i just
direct actors from my home but also most
of the actors are are in their homes so
i've gotten to see over the course the
last two years a lot of people's houses
like i feel like
every time i direct a cartoon or
anything uh i get i get a little glimpse
into their world like are they are we in
someone's closet today or are we in
their weird converted garage and are we
going to see dogs in the background or i
mean some of those amazing
funny moments that happened with people
during during the
um
covered lockdown with zooms you know
little kids running in and then them try
to send them out the room or the guy who
was a cat i mean that yeah that was
great
i just love the fact that it's not a
young kid or someone that can laugh it
off and say oh guys i'm sorry i've got a
filter on my face we can't work out
let's just do the meeting the guy's like
oh
i'm not a cat
judge
billy and dom eat the world
oh so cute hey sam we could talk to you
all day okay
oh okay there's a butt i wasn't
expecting that i'm getting very hungry
oh great okay and uh every every week on
uh the friendship onion we have a
billion dom eat the world
where we try to get some food from at a
different place in the world or maybe
from someone's uh childhood something
that reminds them of something uh so we
asked you to bring in some food and uh
if you could you explain what you
brought in for sure i i i
i
i had to think fast because i do like a
lot of different food and
a total transparency i'm a bit of a food
snob so the stuff i like is is quite
expensive but i i i wanted to bring in
some matzo ball soup
because uh it reminds me of my oma my
grandma uh who was
uh she escaped world war ii germany she
you know and she and uh she she came to
this country with not much except for
her recipes and her plucky outlook on
life and i just remember loving her
matzo ball soup and when i
when i moved to los angeles i moved to
uh an apartment building that was right
next to this deli called cantor's deli
and one of the first meals i had in la
was this matzo ball soup that they have
there uh which which i was like this is
a sign it feels comfortable and
reassuring and it's like i'm being
watched over i don't know i just love it
so much and i thought you guys might
like it too and is that is it right i'm
sure i read somewhere that that's where
the the dailies came from was the jewish
people coming over from europe
getting to new york and there was no
food that they wanted sure so yeah that
sounds right these delis opened up with
all this wonderful food yeah that sounds
about right
to remember where they where they came
from yeah and and i i remember having
uh a lot of things growing up that i
don't think
many kids would find appealing you know
the white fishes and gefilte fishes of
the world and but i loved them i thought
they were great yeah it seemed normal to
me
no one has a business like yours with
all its strengths and challenges to
succeed you need a hiring partner that
adapts to your needs that's indeed if
you're hiring you need indeed because
indeed is the hiring partner where you
can attract interview and hire all in
one place and indeed is the only job
site where you're guaranteed to find
quality applications that meet your
must-have requirements or else you don't
pay
instead of spending hours on multiple
job sites hoping to find candidates with
the right skills you need one powerful
hiring partner that can help you do it
all indeed partners with you in every
step of the hiring process find great
talent through time saving tools like
indeed instant match assessments and
virtual interviews
with instant match as soon as you
sponsor a post you get a short list of
quality candidates with resumes on
indeed that match your job description
and you can invite them to apply right
away plus you only pay for quality
applications that meet your must-have
requirements one of the really great
features is instant match over 90 of
employers get quality candidates as soon
as they sponsor the job post according
to indeed data
candidates you invite to apply through
instant match are three times more
likely to apply to your job than
candidates who only see it in search
start hiring right now with a 75
sponsored job credit to upgrade your job
post at indeed.com onion offer valid
through march 31st go to indeed.com to
claim your 75 credit before march 31st
indeed.com slash onion terms and
conditions apply need to hire you need
indeed
people focus on fitness early in the
year and the trail runner swt is the
first ever running shoe designed for
running on trails that is sustainably
made and designed for durability comfort
and performance ever since i've got my
old bird shoes i wear them all the time
i absolutely love them i love them as
well dom i know i noticed you get red
ones i got blue ones
but they are absolutely fantastic i
really love them the trail runners are
one of the best pair of shoes i've ever
had
so comfortable weatherproof as well
which i like because we have had a
little bit of rain recently in
la
and uh you don't get your feet wet which
is fantastic all birds rigorously road
test the trail runner swt with over 2
000 miles and a hundred runners of all
age abilities and body types they're
durable water repellent as i said they
have a finish on them that helps keep
the water out and keeps your shoes from
getting soggy designed for trail running
the trail runner swt also makes a
fantastic hiking shoe and to make you
feel even better about them dom all
birds is a big corporation making the
environment a stakeholder in their
business they know we can create a more
sustainable future but only if we hold
ourselves accountable hit the trails in
the all birds trail runner swt find your
pair at allbirds.com that's
a-l-l-b-i-r-d-s
[Music]
dot com
canters delhi is is an iconic place to
eat if you're ever in los angeles and i
remember elijah taking me there when i
was on holiday during rings we went to
canter's deli this is back when i was
eating much more meat than i do now we
ordered a rube and the reuben's are
cancer fantastic i mean it's it's this
thick the sandwich full of
corned beef and and pastrami yeah yeah
yeah and then i also ordered an egg
cream oh sure which is
which is it's a strange drink when you
think i mean i don't think that's a
particularly jewish drink but it is
certainly it's a deli drink yeah it's
great it's essentially
a fizzy chocolate milk with egg white on
the top yeah that sounds right
no i know it's good it sounds crazy it's
good and then from uh pudding or dessert
for the first time ever i had a peanut
butter and jelly sandwich
you had never had that never had it we
don't have it in britain really you
don't really not in the same way that
you guys oh it's the best that's about
this i don't know if i'd have a sandwich
as a dessert well i just wanted i was
like oh my god peanut butter and one
time i was saying jam peanut butter and
jam sandwiches never had one and elijah
being elijah who's enthused about
everything oh my god you gotta have one
you gotta have it right now all right so
we ordered one of those but matzo ball
soup correct me if i'm wrong sam
is one of the more
iconic jewish dishes for sure right yes
yes
holla well done well done you were
searching for that for me
i haven't had it in so long probably 20
years
uh yeah they do a good haul of french
toast there are we are we are coming in
we are now going to eat live live on
camera yes that's disgusting
is this a fetish thing
honestly people will watch it they watch
dungeons and dragons
so here comes johnny close
oh my god now oh there's
because it's so gigantic they can't even
fit it in the you don't know also also
rye bread is something that's essential
with this thing
now i'm going to read some stuff about
the matzo book oh you've got research on
matzo ball soup well yeah we do now it
says here
the dum the dumplings are matzo boss
were not always called matzo balls they
were they called dogs i'll tell you
that's what the germans austrians
announced so uh dogs used to oh and our
stations used to come when jewish people
moved to thailand at thailand what is
wrong with me poland oh
when i didn't realize there was a strong
jewish population in thailand when
jewish people moved to poland they
referred to them as
cano de la
okay and in the 1930s the
united states
manischewitz
companies
i'm sorry
my jewish pronunciation i'm i'm the
jewish to english translation thank you
i love it they started packaging the
product and calling them alsatian
feathery balls oh they should have stuck
with that
condition
nathan whoever nathan is says it was
probably u.s comedians and vaudeville
performers that eventually called the
dumplings maxables now do you know where
the where the etymology of matzo comes
from what's matzo about matzah is just
that flat bread that uh that we that we
jews had to eat while crossing the
desert to escape pharaoh listen guys
i'm i have jewish heritage but i am not
a jewish expert okay that should be
fully we're not going to get we're not
giving you big questions about this
we're just eating some food i've never
asked a grown man this before but what
should i do with my blog you should take
your balls yeah you should scoop out a
nice feathery ball yeah and uh just a
chunk of your feathery ball and put it
in the soup and and eat it
really is it lovely
honestly it's not it's much lighter than
you would expect and it's bread is it
it's yeah
it's unleavened bread it doesn't it
doesn't rise like bread because they
didn't have yeast in the desert is that
right yes no no no infections then
yeah they were very
clean crotches in in
on that journey do you make this
i don't but my wife who's vietnamese
does oh so she makes fun as well she
also makes fur yes that's the connect
that's the correct pronunciation right
because a lot of people call it foe it's
not faux in fact if i'm i'm gonna i'm
also full disclosure not a vietnamese
expert guys yeah but uh
uh there is a there is an upswing far
it's almost like a question mark so
people people who pronounce it wrong are
[ __ ]
yes
hey i'm gonna have a taste of this bill
you're gonna love it now you're saying
your gran used to make this where did
she come from in germany she came from
heidelberg
lovely tobogganing
um
but she came here you know when when the
big
diaspora happened and uh
she was my oma and she was great when i
was a kid actor i was a child actor um i
was on a national tour of a of a play
and she came on the whole national tour
with me for a year and a half as a chef
as my chaperone yeah that's brilliant
yeah me and my sister and her that's
brilliant and when she make you food a
lot that's a kind of yes absolutely um
although we did do a lot of hotel living
yeah um
yeah she was awesome and she was a
painter and i love her oh my grandmother
my grandma taught me how to knit when i
had my tonsils out but i was quite a
shoddy knitter and also so she was
disappointed with that and then at the
same time it's kind of a dark moment for
my grandma and i
um she asked me um hey what's your
favorite part of the bible now i was
only i was only 13 at the time how do
you choose right i mean there's so many
good spots well so as a 13 year old boy
there are certain things in the bible
that i found more dynamic than others
like you know daniel and the lion and
and the parting of the the sea and all
that kind of stuff but unfortunately i
plumbed for well my favorite part of the
bible is where jesus gets crucified i
got troubled um off my grandma for that
and she complained to my mum that i was
like a bloodthirsty in some way oh god
we should probably leave christ there
yeah we'll leave it there let's come
back and get back to food speaking
uh speaking not of any of this um you
mentioned elijah before yes um
uh i witched her and i i remembered a
connection that not many i think uh
actors share but i i've i'm told that
you
you both and elijah and maybe sean
all have matching tattoos is that right
are they visible yes
yeah it's myself elijah shawn
billy
orlando viggo ian mckellen john reese
davis is stunt double oh sean bean yeah
sean beam all nine of the fellowship
well nine in the first place a very cool
thing happened when we went back to new
zealand a couple of years later pete
jackson very proudly showed us a tattoo
that he got which instead of the number
nine which we got he got the number ten
oh as a kind of like you know just
outside the group piggyback
so that me that means the number nine in
elvish high elvish i think right
which is the language that only the
kings and queens and royal court in the
elvish community the reason i bring this
up is me and my my fellows my my my
group of critical role
to emulate you
we all got matching tattoos
i was just about to say you guys should
do we did we have vox machina tattoos
each of us i i'd have to like take off
my shirt i'll show you but it's it's on
it's on my shoulder have you all got it
on the same place no no some of us got
it on their arms i think someone has it
on their calf i have it on my back
but yeah we did the same thing how many
actors are involved eight so there's
eight we've got nine yeah i guess you're
one you're one you're one better yes
yeah um he's on his foot yeah maine is
on my foot because that job was a lot to
do with feet
oh that's we got your feet glued on
every day for like four years were those
shoes those feet they were sort of like
slippers rubber slippers
and then they'd have to do the edges and
fade it all in it took an hour every day
to put them on it's hard work anyway
guys back to the soup first oh god it's
so good it's fantastic it goes really
well with rye bread it just complements
it really well but also am i would i be
right in thinking that this is a great
thing if someone's got the sniffles if
someone's got a shoulder
chicken suit for the soul
as a child i would look forward to
getting sick just so i could get some
more of that sweet those those bread
bowls are good though would you say
that's a good one or an it's fantastic
yeah i think that's that's a it's an
absolute delight dumb yeah you've always
loved balls
but those are very fluffy much fluffier
than i would i think it's the first time
i've ever had this really really yeah
i've never had is it matzah matzah yeah
matzah i've never had the bulge before
and that that that's maybe the best part
you know what it's like in scotland we
have dumplings okay and and we put it
like with mints and potatoes and i don't
know how you make those but my grand
used to make those and they were so
fluffy and
yeah that that was a major thing for me
growing up and that reminds me of it you
grew up um
when did you move out of scotland well
only i only moved to america like um
about eight years ago oh and i still go
back to scotland oh wow but my
grandmother was the same always making
and she would make weird stuff
like um
a pig's feet
trotters yeah that kind of thing in
rogers oh weird stuff and she lived to
100 and she
she would never good jeans she would
never um let any food go to waste i
remember once she had a big thing of
about 14 sausages in her fridge
and i said grand these are out a date
like way out
these are like two months out a day and
she cooked them up and ate everyone
you don't want to waste you can't comes
from a time where you can't you can't
waste
14 out of deep sausages and you live to
100. maybe that's the secret maybe it is
when milk used to go off
she would keep it till it went really
off and like started to like solidify
and then she
would call it buttermilk and drink it no
no no that's sour that's not bad
that's incredible yeah i know i bet she
had some really healthy gut flora if
she's drinking for sure if she's
drinking soured milk do you know what i
mean and sausages by the dozen ah that's
insane but who knows maybe she would
have lived to 120 if she hadn't been
eating it yeah that sounds true she's
still alive no two hundred and something
my grandparents used to as far as i know
i'll have to ask my beat you up yeah
used to beat me with him
um no they used to fry hey
cheese just like a block of cheese in a
pan until it became like liquefied
cheese and then pour that into soup
bowls and eat that what dumb a block of
cheese you're listening to me and sam
talking about our grands and now you're
just making up stories
we'll get my mum on to confirm that it
was a block of cheese it was not good
it was it's like a block of cheddar and
they would fry it until it became liquid
and then pour that into soup bowls and
eat that that's not soup that's just a
sauce
i love that doesn't it revert back to
cheese very quickly like doesn't it
become solidified very quickly
okay we'll start this with a round of
applause
because today i'm excited to announce
that manscaped has launched their ultra
premium collection believe it or not
it's not just for your private parts i'm
talking about a leveled up hygiene
routine with your favorite manly scent
and i've tried this dom and it smells
fantastic there's the body stuff there's
the shampoo it is great all-in-one skin
and hair care kit for everyday man that
covers you from head to toe
manscaped is trusted below the waist now
trust it with a rest join the four
million men worldwide who trust
manscaped by going to manscape.com for
20 off and free shipping with the code
onion wow we all know how essential the
manscape tm lawn mower 4.0 is for that
precise trim below the waste their
advanced skin safe technology reduce
cuts to your most delicate of areas it
also includes the hydrating body
moisturizer the body wash a two in one
shampoo and conditioner to make your
showering very easily plus a free gift a
three pack set of lip balm that's made
up with ingredients such as vitamin e
peppermint eucalyptus oils to keep those
choppers feeling moist i really think
they've done a great job with us dom i
think this stuff is real high quality i
really like all of it smells fantastic
and that's four products plus a gift
inside the ultra premium collection what
a score all of these products are
cruelty free paraben free vegan friendly
and dye free the best ingredients with
zero compromise get that ultra premium
collection hot off the shelves get
twenty percent off plus free shipping
with the coat onion at manscape.com
that's 20 off plus free shipping with
the code onion at manscape.com the power
of attraction is now in a bottle thanks
to manscaped
gaps in the diet shouldn't be ignored
over 97 of men aged 19 to 50 are not
getting enough vitamin d from the diet
and 95 are not getting the recommended
daily intake of key omega-3s rituals
essential for men 18 plus multivitamin
was formulated by exhaustive research to
help fill nutrient gaps in the diets of
men aged 18 plus it is formulated with
nutrients to help support brain health
bone health blood health and provide
antioxidant support but ritual doesn't
stop there they invested in a gold
standard university-led clinical trial
to prove the impact of essentials for
men 18 plus multivitamin the results
essential for men 18 plus was shown to
increase vitamin d levels by 43
and omega-3 dha levels by 41
in 12 weeks the clinical study was
published in leading scientific journal
frontiers in nutrition a published
clinical study is a big deal and a
serious commitment to a first of a kind
standard in the industry
ritual is committed to third-party
testing from usp and the non-gmo project
traceable and vegan-friendly ingredients
and always clear communication no shady
stuff that's great news i have to say
billy when i have a regular
uh ritual of taking a multivitamin every
day i feel fantastic and it kind of
helps me avoid little things like maybe
a sore throat here and there or a cold
because you're getting all the stuff
that you need on a regular basis and if
you're not sure if you're getting enough
sun or you're not getting enough uh
vegetables in your diet
get your ritual right now ritual is
offering our listeners 10
off for your first three months visit
ritual.com
onion and turn healthy habits into a
ritual that's 10 off at ritual.com
onion
hey more stuff about um
oh we're doing a deep dive yeah
the whole matzah landscape shifted when
the manuschevitz is that right could be
yeah thank you when the manuscripts
company burst onto the scene like
michael richards according to labels
table this food company started
operations back in eight excuse me 1888
wow and began mass producing his
signature matzah in order to placate
jewish people who didn't approve of the
commercialization of the sacred bread
the founder of the company journeyed to
israel to study the talmud the talmud
for 13 years winning over naysayers now
what is the talmud it's one of those an
old cookery book it's not a cookbook it
is it is this uh one of the central
books of the jewish faith ah so for him
to be more of a kind of uh
legitimate person that could make the
maximal he
studied the jewish i guess i guess so
yes i'll tell you what i love can we
give it some points
really wait so you guys rate the food
yeah we reach it tell him tell sam hey
wait what if this is terribly
embarrassing for you oh it's fantastic
but i'll tell you what my chin is wet
because i've been eating it so much
you've covered the mic in grease i don't
care dumb it's delicious it is i've
actually finished my macro bowl yeah
it's time nutritious so here's how we
mark it there's three categories
aesthetics okay and or looks
and then
the third one my particular favorite
category
is usefulness usefulness how useful is
that oh interesting yes okay okay and
that would be like if you use it for
occasions or to well
i guess that's for you guys to discuss
yeah sometimes it'll be you know for
instance we got
jardinera is a sort of spicy thing that
we did on here once and it's like um
chili's and an oil and you could put it
in eggs and you could put it on pizza
and you could make things with it and
that got a high usefulness yeah okay
okay
i got it but first off taste i'm gonna
go first because i thought it was
wonderful you loved it
you can put points on it and it is so a
10. okay
9.8 holy crap wow that's big i was i was
a perfect 10. i was hungry dom and the
ball the matzo ball was much more
beautiful and a great texture than i
expected whenever i saw it i thought it
looked heavy but that was beautiful and
light and i'll definitely have that
again nine point eight wow so one of the
things it's important to know about
billy is he's a simple man sure he likes
si not not you're not a simple turn no
i'm a simple you like simple things you
know wake up cup of coffee maybe go for
a walk on the beach keep life simple no
drama no [ __ ] you know what i mean
and i think this soup
speaks to your personality do you know
what i mean it's just simple it's
noodles i know what it is there's some
broth it's balls you love balls i love
it i love balls this is fantastic do you
want to give it a score out of 10 sam
well i i mean yeah yeah i'm going to be
10 across the board
yeah i mean i bought it i brought it in
this is my favorite okay well of course
would you say it's your favorite soup of
all time yeah this
this soup is very special to me matzo
ball soup and also far i was gonna say
be married to a vietnamese lady they're
big on liquidy soupy
if i could only eat those two soups for
the rest of my life i'd be happy oh
gazpacho for me i'm in love with
gazpacho i love it and also in in
barcelona they do a slight
uh kind of
different vibe with gazpacho it's called
salmorejo
and they add uh some
egg and some onion and some peppers and
on a hot spanish day when you've been
sweating and you're losing some salt oh
gazpacho and also that thai soup that we
dumb what give our squash i'm so excited
about it i've been here for about three
hours i'm sorry score
i'm going to give it i'm going to be a
little bit more conservative sure you
guys
i liked it
eight
i'm gonna give it an 8.1
well that's all right actually that's
81. that's very good i won't tell my
dead grandmother oh god what you said no
don't don't about that thank you omar
now aesthetics the look well it's it's
nice i mean it's
the carrots are little little blocks
okay what would you prefer julianne
ripped off some yeah ripped what a
ripped carrot
different different sizes i don't like
it when it looks as if it's come out
like
a
you
and feels
in your mouth
much better than it looks it looks like
a testicle like a gigantic testicle yeah
it's not like a dragon's bowl yeah yeah
yeah so i really can't give a high
absolutely i'm only going to give her a
6.2
that's totally fair okay
um
you're giving it 10 across the board no
no no
all right i got i gotta i gotta be
realistic here this is not a good
looking soup it's not the best looking
it's nowhere near as good looking as it
is good tasting so i'm gonna i'm gonna
give it a 6.5 for looks i like the balls
yeah i do like the balls
yeah i'll throw on an eight just because
i think natural right i like looking at
a nice meaty
ball yeah it would look better now
usefulness first of all
it seems to be at the top of the list if
you were to get a cold or something like
that for sure just raised it to a deli
and get some matzo ball soup
doesn't have a ton of other uses other
than you know just i mean you're not
really
you're not going to make a pie out of it
no definitely not you're not going to
freeze it and make an ice pop no no no
definitely not i like to think this is
one of my things can i take it to a
sporting event definitely not no and
can you share it with people i mean
you're not all going to have spoons and
certainly not in the days of covid i
mean i guess if you went to a sporting
event and you had one of those helmets
with the straws that oh yes your head
yeah one at one half could be the matzo
ball and one half could be the soup i
don't know the macho bowl wouldn't it be
a thick chip wouldn't yeah you could oh
sorry you'd have to like slice it up and
stuff so the little bits could come down
that's when the ripped carrots would
come in the ripped carrots god they're
ripped so a dome i can't give a high one
it's not massive for usefulness but
other but it's very
i mean it can only be a five point one
i'm afraid that's fair that's fair it's
nice at the top sam i'll i'll throw in i
still uh thought that it was very useful
for me personally and reminding me of
home so i'll give it a seven and a half
yeah yeah
i'm gonna give it a seven and a half two
it does exactly what it says it's going
to do makes you feel
comfy and great inside but it doesn't do
a huge amount else no but i do love it
thanks for bringing that oh thank you
for eating eating my balls
[Applause]
i mean you've enjoyed some billion
dollar meat the world stuff before
i would say that's in the top
four or five of most infused i've seen
you with the food it was really
delicious tom i did really love it and
the manzo ball was much much better than
i thought it was going to be awesome
imagine the next time you you're coming
down with a little bit of a head cold
you don't really feel like going out and
you say to your son hey
son i'll just call him son in case he
doesn't want to get flamed on the show
can you run to the deli and grab me a
large matzo ball certainly comes back
and it fills your soul with goodness you
know my wife still talks about the day
when she had a terrible cold
and elijah wood turned up at her door
with a big pot of a chicken noodle soup
ah
and wow she thought that was the kindest
thing and she was so during the movie or
just randomly like
like way after wow like ten years really
are a fellowship
well does she not talk about the fact
that a couple of weeks ago i bought her
a all bells and whistles italian meal or
has she just forgotten about that she
you know she's never brought that up
really
you could have a bolognese you could
have a ragu you could have a bruschetta
there'd still be enough room for a
bottle of wine and she's not said a
thing and i'm wearing a t-shirt i'm
going to win
i'm going to rip it
you bought her books you bought a gift
never never mentions it what has she
done for me and what is the only thing
she ever brings up is elijah wood
brought her soup once wow well we know
my favorite is i mean elijah's pretty
charming he's a wonderful man with
massive eyes yeah just spookily massive
eyes yes it's a it's it's a problem i
think his kids have uh adopted those
eyes as well
[Music]
um
we're gonna listen to some music now we
are is that there's a regular feature in
the show okay it's non-stop this show
isn't it there's a lot going on i'll
just try i'll i gotta i gotta get one of
those uh nondescript energy drinks
we're almost done okay okay thank you
very much for coming on yeah thank you
this has been a blast it's a really
really fun now you've brought to us a
a kind of established funk meister
um it's a little indie artist i don't
think you've you've heard of him before
okay let's see let's have a listen yeah
i don't know if you've
let's see been exposed
[Music]
[Music]
but yeah brilliant he played all the
instruments on that whole album he's
like prince and the whole album yeah and
all the vocabulary that's innovations
that's inner visions yes i cho i i don't
i didn't know what song to choose so i
keeping in the theme of of when i first
moved to la that was a song that i
listened to a lot uh when i first moved
to la because if i can
if i can name drop for a second one of
my one of my first gigs in la was i was
the apprentice editor on an on a quentin
tarantino film which phil
jackie brown oh wow great movie um
and uh he is a music lover yeah uh we
actually edited the movie in his house
in his basement so i was in his house
all the time and he had stacks and
stacks of cds
sorry we're old yeah uh cds at the time
of just music everywhere every just
music music music and uh one afternoon
he was just like hey just take some to
take whatever you want just listen take
whatever you want listen to and he's
like try try this one he threw me the
inner visions disc and i listened to it
like non-stop i thought it was the
coolest thing ever
so it reminds me of like my
my uh my time uh when i first moved to
l.a brilliant and what an extraordinary
artist steven wonder unbelievable
originally called little stevie wong yes
there you go because he's because he
came up burst onto the scene at like the
kids 14 15 right just did protege were
you guys kid actors or kid performers i
mean we were acting but we weren't
getting paid for him no i wasn't now i
was a kid bookbinder i used to make
books you made books as a child well not
as like
as an eight-year-old you were that was
in the first place that was the first
real job oh okay okay
my first job was at a uh post office
sorting mail oh god yeah but get this
right this is so stupid you would be
awful at that i was terrible at sorting
mail with my mate martin killheaney hi
my name is
listening hi martin and we went we went
to this post office just a sorting
office you know
come in and then and then you go right
this goes to liverpool this goes to
london this goes to sheffield whatever
and for some reason
myself and martin kellini tried to
convince the other men in the sorting
office that we were members of the
biggest boy band in england at that
point which was take that take that take
that where robbie williams goes oh
that's right so i told well we told them
that i was mark owen no and he was jason
orange and we would do dances for them
and they must have been looking at us
thinking you guys are so stupid because
why would you be
sorting mail for like two quid an hour
when you're the biggest pop band in
england then we kept it up well i would
have been laughing at us maybe maybe
everyone knew that robbie was going to
go solo and the band was going to break
up yeah that was a tragic story that's
just like i remember there's times in
your life where you look back and you're
kind of mortified i remember saying what
were we doing then but i was such a fan
of take that that i just went for it um
my son was skating
i told you this and then i dropped him
and he's mate off at the ramp no he's
mate's house and his dad came up to say
hello
and i was like i recognize him and when
i drove away it was my cohen from take
that
wow who was kind of before robbie kind
of exploded and take that mark owen was
consistently thought of as the sexual
dreamboat wasn't he and now also when
they split up
i liked his music the best out of all of
them when they all did their solo shows
talking about music you write the music
right for your character oh yes my
character
yes my character sings and i also i also
uh co-write the music that he sings they
are brilliant songs i love them they're
funny
thank you
choking and i'm at so bad that's
understandable it's a it's a thick soup
it's brilliant bro anyway we give this
uh marks as well tell them how we do
this one you're you're ranking stevie
wonders yeah yes classic yes we ranked
drug anthem yeah we rank these songs
based on levels of funk and girls are
funky it goes from brahms who you could
argue has no level of funk
no all the way up to
prince that is most purple which is a
high level of funk yes and we've
actually scored it before but on stevie
wonder i certainly have
um
does anyone want to go first
you do
i would rate this song
at
sly in the family stone peak level funk
wow yeah i mean it is to get higher than
that and funk can mean a few things to a
few people yeah it doesn't have to be
fun you often have a funky sack i do
i would put this with i mean it's pretty
you can't get more funky so you're
funkadelic yeah i'm saying it's
funkadelic you're [ __ ] down yeah it's
funny yeah that's that's fair that's
pretty funky i'll give it nine out of
ten george clinton's that's a george
level
right it's up there these are all iconic
funk meisters i mean stevie wonder's
better it's an amazing album i can't
believe you've got that album
from quentin town too yeah he has
doubles of everything he's a sloppy guy
he had a lot of extras of things around
the house he's got a little bit of cash
to splash around doesn't he we met
stevie wonder do you remember that no
way oh yeah we met him billy and i went
to one of these very uh you know bougie
uh gifting sweets you know these things
that happen i've heard of them i've
never been to one you'll be going
sampson no it won't be long so around
awards season i don't think it's
happening this year it hasn't happened
for a while around awards season because
so many people flop into los angeles
some of these companies will set
themselves up in hotel rooms and invite
people to come in maybe take a photo
with a product and they'll give you that
product it's kind of i'm embarrassed it
was true though isn't it
and we were at one of these things
because my mate greg who uh accidentally
uh suntanned only part of his face whoa
yeah so he was like two-face
from from the batman story he really was
and he went to the emmy so
i'll try and keep this story very short
i flew him out to la to come hang out
with us for the emmys i think right i
can't remember what it was for we were
staying at the wyndham bellage hotel now
the london hotel we were at the pool for
breakfast billy and i said okay we're
going to go mooch about on sunset
boulevard have some fun said to my mate
greg what do you want to do he was like
mate i'm i've not seen sun for like
eight months i'm going to lie here by
the pool and get some stuff on my side
on one side and we said all right we'll
we'll come back in a couple of hours get
ready get dressed he fell asleep by the
pool and completely sunk boy inside of
his face and he when he so when he
showed up at the emmys
he was trying to only get photos on one
side wow billy was in hysterics it was
um very funny
wait why would why did i mention him in
terms of um
stevie wonder oh wait so so we were at a
gifting suite my friend greg used to
work for a clothing line called bench
and they had a little set up okay
so greg said to billy and i will you
come to the booth and take some pictures
in some bench attire and stuff and we
did
and as we were leaving
stevie wonder showed i mean he didn't
know that's a superstar
yeah
a legend an icon and for the right
reason he's making amazing stuff
extraordinary artist yeah wow
hey hey it was a good song have we run
out of time yeah we've run out of time
there's a couple of facts here about too
high but i don't think we're going to
get around that's right
we'll just see it's brilliant yeah
he was stoned when he wrote it he was
stoned when he recorded it too high yeah
that's great that's all you really need
to know this has been a fantastic
episode um please you guys out there go
watch vox machina it's available on
amazon prime internationally
international
honestly it is absolutely wonderful i
loved it and up to now and it's going to
get even better because dawn monahan's
going to be in it
playing a scotsman and the entire time i
was playing this scotsman
i was thinking of billy connolly oh
wow chloe close that one up
kicking the matzo balls
all right hey sam it's been brilliant
having you on thanks for having me this
is so much fun maybe you can uh come
back at some point and uh help us out
with our continued adventures into
trying to get billy to play yeah yeah i
i really enjoyed that little five
minutes that we did where we can make it
we can make it a full hour next time i
would like
thanks a lot
[Music]
you're my pearl